(electronic music)
- [Narrator] Previously, on Bro-Dependent.
- [Anderson Voiceover] I'm working on this
like really exciting energy drink project,
but Oxycontin is super expensive on
the black market.
- Anderson, I am not
investing in your drug drink.
- Will you marry me?
- Oh my God, no.
- Why the fuck did you do this?
- Shh, it's okay, it's okay.
- I'll never love again.
- Zac, it's not your fault, okay?
Like, you're so trusting, you know,
you're such a kind spirit.
- I know.
- Zac, no dude, don't cry.
Dude, when you cry, dude, it
straight up breaks my heart, okay?
Cheer the fuck up, dude.
It's gonna be okay.
Things are looking up, okay?
You and I are back on good terms,
your like, financial
contribution to Quatro-Contin's
gonna like, take this
shit to the next level.
We're gonna be crazy rich, dude.
We're gonna be like, Dennis
Quaid rich, you know?
- Totally and then
Carolyn will want me back.
- No, you have to stop saying that, okay?
- No, she will, dude, I swear.
- I'm not saying that she wouldn't,
I'm saying that it's
not good for you, okay?
- It's fine, dude.
- Look guys, shut up. Are you
gonna buy this oxy or not?
- Yeah, oh sorry, oxy dude.
Yes, yes, we want to buy the oxy.
- Then give me the money.
- Oh, ah, ah, ah (laughs) I'm sorry dude,
I'm on some right now
and I'm like wa lala la lala la.
Dude, Zac, fucking hook
this drug dealer up, okay?
- Fuck yeah.
- All right.
- Drug deal.
- Why the hell did you
guys want to meet in
a mall parking lot on a Sunday for anyway?
- Oh, it's one of those
like, hide in plain sight
sort of deals, you know?
Hey girl.
Sick mom jeans.
Also, they've got a Mrs. Field's in there
and I super feel like a
cookie cake right now.
- All right.
- What the fuck is this?
- Oh, it's your money, dude.
Sorry it's like messy or whatever,
but this is all I could find in my room.
It's 10,000 dollars though.
- Hey guys.
- [Group] Oh, shit, run!
- Hey, woah, hey.
I just need you guys to move your car.
There's a lot of spaces, so.
All right, have a good one.
- Hey, wait, wait, wait,
wait, hey dude, dude, hey.
You didn't see nothing, okay?
- You just pay on your way out.
- Okay then.
- Okay.
- Holy shit.
Okay, I think we're fine.
- So, what are you guys
gonna do with all this?
- Oh, I am selling a new energy drink
with Oxycontin in it.
- So, you're a drug dealer.
- No, why the fuck does
everyone keep saying that?
You're the drug dealer, douchebag.
- No, actually I'm a cop
and you're under arrest
for buying a Schedule One
narcotic with intent to sell.
Get your hands where I can see em!
- Oh shit, Schedule One?
- You have the right to remain silent.
- Wait, wait, dude, dude, dude, calm down.
If we ask him he's a cop and
he says no, that's entrapment.
Are you a cop?
- Yeah, and you're under arrest.
- Oh shit, run!
- Ahh!
- Zac, oh my god, Zac!
Oh fuck, oh god.
Zac, I'm sorry, dude.
This is all my fault,
this is all my fault.
- Stop, listen, listen.
Did it look cool when got hit by that car?
- Yeah dude, it was so cool.
- Cool.
- It was so funny, dude.
Zac?
Oh my god, Zac?
You were like, "Oh, owie,"
it was so funny, dude.
It was so sad, dude.
It was so sad.
It was so funny and it was so sad.
I love you, Zac.
Don't be dead!
Zac!
Hey, thanks for watching Bro-Dependent on
Comedy Central's YouTube channel.
Um yeah, comment and subscribe.
And I've sincerely hope you enjoyed
watching my best friend
fucking die for you enjoyment.
Yeah, well leave a comment
in the comments section
and tell me what other
fucking important people
in my life you'd like to watch die,
so you can go, "How funny!".